humer le parfum des fleurs respirer au
grand air et pourquoi pas faire de
bonnes affaires à chédigny la rose est à
la fête
les visiteurs sont ravis il ya des
jolies fleurs des rosiers magnifique
tout et motta un très beau voyage que je
ne connaissais pas du tout en dehors de
la fête des roses je pense que ça gagne
à être connu tout à fait c'est important
d'avoir un des conseils de
professionnels pour la pour replanter
pour la sueur de la vie au futur du
rosier et pour le plaisir qu'on va en
tirer
même enthousiasme du côté des exposants
non non non c'est des variétés qui se
tiennent tout seul
pépiniéristes rosiéristes renoue le
contact avec leurs clients l'année 2020
bah comme pour beaucoup de gens a été
assez compliqué puisque toutes les fêtes
des plantes ont été annulés les unes
après les autres toutes les
manifestations genou on participe
également à des concours de rose ont
fait également des conférences on
organise des cours de taille donc
évidemment tout ça avait été mis entre
parenthèses en 2020 et début 2000 21
donc retrouver tout ça c'est vrai que
c'est quand même très très agréable
contexte sanitaire oblige les
organisateurs de l'événement ont dû
revoir leurs ambitions à la baisse pas
d'animation dans les rues cette année
capacité d'accueil limitée à 4 mètres
carrés par visiteur mais l'essentiel est
ailleurs
ça fait vivre nos les personnes qui ont
des gîtes des chambres d'hôtes les
restaurants tout ce qui a un petit peu
autour de notre village et
et du fait qu'on fait partie de koné sur
la le chemin de la rose ça amène aussi
pas mal de monde quoi bonne nouvelle si
vous l'avez manquée la fête se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche dans la soirée